So now we need to build and
install the application.
Remember, there are two parts,
the phone application and
the wearable application.
Before, I mentioned that
the wearable application
needs to be embedded into
the phone application.
While this is required for
distribution through Google Play.
it's actually possible to build and
deploy them separately for testing.
So let's walk through how to build and
deploy our new application for testing.
And then we can discuss
the embedding later.
You'll notice here there are two
Gradle projects, Mobile and Wear.
We can build and
install each of these separately.
So make sure you connect
up your phone now.
And ensure that the Android Debug Bridge
is working properly.
Now select the mobile project,
and click the green Play button.
This tells Gradle to run
the Assemble Debug task.
Which compiles your code and
makes an APK out of it.
Android Studio then installs
it to your device or emulator.
We may need to select
a device to install it to.
So select that,
in this case, my Nexus 5.
And click okay to continue.
After waiting a minute or two.
You'll see the phone side of your
application running on the phone.
This is exactly the same as what
you would have done previously
when you learned Android programming.
Now to get to the important part,
building the wearable
side of the application.
We now need to get your wearable paired
up over ADB just like your phone.
Most Android Wear devices would come
with a cradle, like one of these.
That allows you to connect to USB cable.
So we make sure we've
got those connected up.
Also, you'll need to enable
developer mode and usb debugging.
So you need to go to Settings, About,
and tap on the Build number seven times.
Then you go to developer mode and
enable USB Debugging.
Your wearable will ask you if you want
to approve the permission request.
Once this is done,
your wearable will be able to use ADB.
If you're a Windows user, I've provided
a link in the instructor notes.
To some documentation that shows how to
set up ADB for Android Wearable Devices.
If you have a wearable device
that does not have a USB cradle.
You can also set up ADB over Bluetooth.
The instructor notes will have a link
that has more information about what you
need to do that as well.
Now that we have the wearable
device set up with ADB.
We need to build the Wearable project.
Let's select the Wearable Gradle project
and click the green Play button.
This tells Gradle to run
the assemblydebug task,
similar as before, but this time for
the Wearable side instead.
Once it finishes building,
Android Studio will prompt you for
which device to install the APK to.
Since there are now two
devices connected by ADB.
It's very important that you
pick the wearable device.
If you pick the wrong one,
the app will not execute properly.
So we select the wearable,
then we click okay.
Now you'll see the wearable activity
appear on the wearable devices.
So that's how you can easily test and
debug phone and wearable apps
from within Android Studio.
When you're ready to push the APK
to your users via Google Play.
You'll need to do these
steps a little differently.
You need to boot a release mode APK.
Which is different than a debug
APK because it is signed with your
development keys to
prove you built the APK.
You can start this process
by using the build menu and
selecting generate signed APK.
Which uses the gradle assemble
release task internally.
And this is how we go
start that process.
Build, generate signed APK.
And then you can follow through
by selecting the mobile project.
And at this point now, you need
to provide all your key details.
And then continue through
with the rest of the process.
I'm not going to go through
that process right now though.
So let's just hit cancel to
get back to where we were.
If you go to the mobile
build.gradle file, like shown here.
You can see there's a property
called wearApp at the bottom.
That references the ware gradle project.
This task tells gradle to embed
the wearable APK into the phone APK.
You should note that this
only happens in release mode.
When we did the testing
earlier in debug mode.
There was no app embedding.
So it's important that you test
your final APK in release mode
by installing it to a phone.
And checking that it syncs over
to the wearable correctly.
If you make a mistake with any
of the wearable packaging steps,
it'll fail to install in the wearable.
By the way, if you're trying to debug
packaging installation problems.
You can use adb logcat and search for
the process WearablePkgInstaller
on the phone and wearable side.
Which will tell you what the problem is.
Oh and one more thing.
I mention build.gradle files, but
did not go into much detail on them.
For many cases you won't need
to edit these very often.
But if you want to learn more.
We have a whole class on Gradle that
teaches you everything you need to know.
About dealing with dependencies and
Multiple Build Flavors.
For a link check the instructor notes.